welcome to this video I'm playing water
again water one of the frequent
opponents 10 games played and have a
slight plus score let's try the Kings
Indian again ah the exchange yeah not
that it is so so grade or anything but
it always feels like you want some
action and then they go like that yeah
this slide recently got recommended in a
book by Bulgarian Graham was the boy
cough which cough not quite sure about
the pronunciation he even mentioned that
this is a line i'm going to try that out
i really have no idea but you mentioned
that this is in fact interesting so
let's let's try right very very nice got
very nice positional compensation here
um night before may be interesting okay
so I'm getting getting at least another
pawn here okay the chance to grab one of
the pawns to go back it's a bit of a
loss of time involved so but ok this is
a this is quite nice quite nice position
for for an exchange I've got a pawn for
it enter nice activity
interesting and it's not really a boring
position yeah what should why do I
really don't know maybe maybe age 32
force this meta here I can take a free
play 96 I have excellent dark square
control anticipation on everyone is
really really not great okay the
question is should i take one of three
or not I don't know let's let's let's
decide on something and take in yeah
this is the reason now we can he could
actually recapture if I should decide to
take I wonder if I could play knight c6
to give for maybe maybe this is an idea
anyway getting the night into central
play yeah like the piece that I have for
the rook is basically the fantastic
bishop on g7 and night on night possibly
going to d4 yarn actually one of the
funny move back of course I don't tell
help them to develop just retreating
here intending 94 as well okay maybe he
wants to play Bishop g4 I have 95 though
it's a it's not bad with a b3 and then
a5 a4 yeah why not come on let's do that
not let's spend more time
now that that is quite dangerous here be
for a three this is a very dangerous
pawn yeah beef before a three tier two
there's also be five
and takes rook takes over this is
fantastic play
by the way I'm sorry about the slight
background sound that you might have in
this video and then and some of the ones
that were recorded right before that
because I have some some people in front
of my house theatre that they are
cutting down trees and bushes it it is a
constant constantly irritating sound
like this is this bus or sound um okay
what what what here it looks nice but
how do I actually how do i actually get
ahead if I get rook a four and maybe
bouquet for how does he prevent the rook
capture king be three there's a la to
happening there's a tube
ya know I just I just wanted to take
here but maybe I have something better
if I play what about c5 actually takes
and then B takes e4 intending c3 check
oh that's it looks very nice let's let's
go for that
look before simply what was good as well
I mean no no question but this looks
more more forceful bc5 bc form intending
c3 check Wow poo yeah what about them
specialist bishops isn't this great e
six and e5 they're both attacking and
protected a favor and great very very
nice a piece coordination okay it's got
the sea porn but wow really can afford
that okay no no use in thinking long
about this um should be three maybe
number should be three will play look
see one giving giving up the exchange
maybe look before to be two is this the
right way to go yeah maybe maybe put it
down the Seaport I mean this is still
still not very dangerous this the six
bishop covering it the c7 bishop
covering it so rupee wanna go look be
too of course
maybe just use the king of this whole
situation is a very problematic form for
white maybe just maybe I can just
approach with the king he cannot really
move anything yeah maybe he can try to
return here on c3 but rooks III desrook
b3 and winning a whole row p.m. so not
not any problem I can just use the king
as well maybe maybe am I maybe if I go
here here time down a check then then
you can maybe return on c3 but I don't
need to check the exchange I can just I
can just walk with my king actually oh
wait if i take here Brooks III Bishop f5
isn't this like totally deadly yeah this
this must be winning come on this is
just too much threatening this diagonal
it's too much look after you get two
wins the rook here and maybe I also
haven't made somewhere hook be 4i come
on let's check let's win the rook that's
enough
before I'm misjudging something and
blinded organs and blunder stuff the
sister is the easiest way yeah this is a
funny line really isn't this with night
XD five I really I really cannot tell
you what what the exact verdict is on
this but it's a it looks interesting
White has some some decent decent some
serious on some coordination problem
this is probably necessary and how this
feels very natural for black I mean it's
a very active position at the same I
mean Marty I really feel that this
should be sufficient compensation ok it
also possible are in many many ways and
here I know this this this holds thing
here gets gets tricky I was thinking
maybe you should go g3 and to try to get
rid of one of the pawns here but ok I've
got 94 as well well it's just not great
this 91 idea and probably wasn't really
helpful yeah this this now gets gets
really really dangerous we have group
before it's also strong and here yeah
this instance isn't assessed as so great
Bishop g4 ok ok Bishop g4 I didn't see
this is a very good defense but does
this mean actually I then then then I
should just take here with the good game
here well this was the easy solution
play like that yeah actually the
computer gives this is totally winning
yeah but I was thinking this looks very
nice and looks very active but I had
overlooked this is this is losing man
and I had overlooked this move the point
being that after f5 this rookie one
and this is all this all this is not
that clear really it is very complicated
but it's not clear what that really
happens yeah can I tell you a computer
gives 000 but it's a total mess at the
way it happened check it was a it was a
complete when ya Bishop b3 also winning
but I just think that whatever I did was
totally sufficient here it's just a one
it's their checkmate here though rupee
three years winning all pieces yeah but
ok we're too was enough that's a funny
funny line here this this night txt five
may be worth considering 444 Kings
Indian player the set up okay thanks for
watching